this is great this is a great moment I
I'm so so thankful to be a storyteller I
think even greater role in society than
being a storyteller though is the role
of teacher and so I first need to thank
the many teachers that have helped me
get to this point my professors at
Stanford University professors at
Brigham Young University where I studied
before and the many many teachers that
I've had along the way they know who
they are I need to thank my film making
partner I'll be seeing who helped me
also appear at Stanford and of course
the greatest teachers in my life are my
parents who are here my father taught me
great work ethic my mother put up with
many many many many questions that I had
as a child and that's definitely served
me as a documentary filmmaker I need to
thank my wife above all for putting up
with the stresses of this film even
though she was pregnant she provided
some of the greatest insights that
helped me complete this film and make my
biggest editing breakthroughs and I need
to definitely thank the subjects of my
film and their families it takes great
courage to allow strangers into your
life with a camera and they were very
courageous in that way and of course the
Academy for making us all feel like
kings for a week thank you